They were supposed to be safe in a country
that prides itself on being welcoming and
inclusive.
But the massacres at two of their places of
worship have stunned the people of Christchurch.
"It really hit home because I used to go to
that mosque, used to play there, hang out
there with my friends and stuff so seeing
that something like this has happened it almost
doesn’t feel real…
We thought islamophobia and xenophobia and
racism is something distant is something that
happened in America and England.
But it’s here and it is dangerous."
This center is providing information and psychological
support to friends and relatives who still
don’t know the fate of their loved ones.
Sahra Ahmed is one of those awaiting news.
She says the attacks will change New Zealand
forever.
"I think what should change is the intelligence
gathering to spread out and not only focused
on one community and it seems like security
has dropped the ball."
The authorities here are still on high alert.
This is one of the two mosques where dozens
were murdered as they met to pray on Friday
afternoon.
"As you can see the scene has been heavily
cordoned off and police have warned other
mosques to keep doors closed for now.
People here show how deeply that’s affected
people- talked to people who cried all night
because they couldn’t believe something
like this could happen in New Zealand."
But A police warning for people to stay inside
couldn’t keep these residents of Christchurch
from paying their respect to the Muslim victims
at a makeshift memorial.
"Most people here aren’t from Muslim communities
because they don’t feel safe
we want to show that we support them."
"This is a city where people band together;
we've been through quakes together.
This is just so far from the city that I know."
Today, Christchurch is in mourning and doubling down on its values as a multicultural society.